the way to win
is as old as time
do the right thing
and put in the framework
[Music]
there's just nothing else by the way
there's nothing else in anything
how do i become a professional hockey
player
talent and effort how do i become a
tremendous top 1 lawyer
talented effort how do i become a
phenomenal mother
talent and effort it's talent and effort
and what what i love about effort and
why i love hustle and now that it's
become so cliche you see me saying the
word work a little bit more now because
i just want people to get it
it's controllable how many people here
want to be a millionaire do you know how
rare that is have you run the math
you have this enormous audacity
yet you're not putting in the work to
get you there because you think somehow
you've been tricked
by yourself or somebody else
that there's some system
like really we're the place now where
kids think it's cool if somebody goes
and takes money out of a bank and puts
it on their
bed and takes a picture of it like what
the [ __ ] does it matter with you you
know what really sucks
it sucks when you buy a 20 000 rolex and
the world collapses and you have no
money and your rolex is worth four
thousand that sucks that's why i always
say i'm a tortoise and a hare's costume
you know zero people zero people that
have built something big that haven't
put in a ridiculous amount of work and
the bigger it is the more they've worked
so i think you have to execute against
your truth people can smell things so
many of you have your mouth way ahead of
your actions really you're going to own
an island and you go to coachella
you when it comes from a true place you
win and when it doesn't you don't like i
wasn't born six foot seven and can run
like a cheetah i could wish i was
something
or i can realize i am something and try
to maximize on that it's a game of poker
you get a hand
nobody's going to cry for you
about your hand nobody's going to say oh
it's terrible that you're not fast or
tall or gorgeous or telling or or can
sing it is what it is and now the only
thing that can happen
is you can figure out how to navigate it
the second you stop dwelling and the
second you stop start doing everything
changes they don't give a [ __ ] the
second you understand that and just
start trying to make it happen with that
energy you win
nobody cares about my problems nobody
has ever cared about my problems my
problems seem far less silly now i got
problems i don't want to be here on a
saturday when my family's not here i got
problems but guess what i mean my bed
i'm making my choices i got my reality
every single person here has
all of you you all have
do the white dudes have it better yes
guess what they still have
everybody's got and nobody cares about
your [ __ ] they care about their [ __ ]
because everybody's got you so nobody
cares about your complaining go do
something and that's it
like what you think somebody's gonna
come along be like oh we're so sorry
they don't care for a reason you got it
that's it
want to be happy build a life not just
the business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the seven rich people habits that you
need to try
enjoy
habit number two is read books with j
shetty so many of you have been asking
me jay how do you read so many books how
do you get through them what's your
strategy what's your approach do you
even sleep the answer to all those
questions is in this video now how many
of you have a stack of books that's
taller than you that you really want to
read this year this month this week and
it just keeps growing and you keep
looking at a schedule and thinking i've
got less time this week than i had last
week and maybe you're thinking i don't
even know where to start reading is
super important i've found it really
fulfilling in my life and really useful
and insightful as well i want to share
with you what some of the most
successful people in the world think
about books warren buffett says that he
spends five to six hours a day reading
five newspapers bill gates reads about
50 books a year mainly business health
engineering diseases mark zuckerberg
says that he reads books to learn and
educate himself about different cultures
and backgrounds oprah calls reading her
personal path to freedom mark cuban says
that he reads to learn about new
industries now this is gonna tell me how
old you are if you remember the
britannica encyclopedia elon musk said
that he read that by the time he was
nine in total and this is my favorite
one phil knight the ceo of nike said
that he kept his library so sacred that
when people entered it they had to take
off their shoes and bow down so there's
plenty of good reasons why you should
read but you really need to know your
own that's my number one tip you need to
know why you're going to read a book is
it because you want to be entertained
and have an escape is it because you
want to learn new information and grow
is it because you want to find new ideas
about how to improve your life the
closer you get clarity on your vision
for why you're reading a book the more
likely you're going to be a successful
reader now before we go into how i read
a book a day for
365 days i want to talk to you about the
biggest mistakes we make as readers one
of the biggest mistakes we make is that
we think that books need to be read
cover to cover whether they're this size
or this size now the interesting thing
is that not all books are written in
that way it's kind of like saying when
you go shopping for your groceries that
you need to walk through every aisle to
just find the things you needed
this is taking way too long you never do
that you take a list you go to the
specific hours and you grab what you
need books are no different you can find
especially with non-fiction books which
is what i'm talking about today you can
find what you need much quicker and make
it much more useful than going through
every single page the second biggest
mistake is that we make reading all
about willpower instead of love power if
you're dragging yourself through a book
and trying to get through to the last
page and every page is a struggle and
feels heavier than the last one and the
words seem to like get smaller every
single time and your eyes are getting
tired it means you're relying on your
willpower and you're not quite making it
through but really we should be relying
on our love power if there's something
you really love something that you're
excited to learn something that you're
energized when you hear about speak
about or read about that's where you
want to throw your energy don't just
read a book because someone told you to
don't just read a book because it was
number one on the new york times
bestseller list read a book because
you're passionate about that subject
okay so those are the biggest mistakes
i'm now going to show you how i read a
book a day for one whole year now i'm
not gonna be teaching you a new
technique that's gonna take you a year
to learn before you even start reading
or something that you need to practice
i'm gonna share really practical simple
tips on how to read more
faster better
so the first thing i do before i start
reading a book is i find the ted talk i
find the youtube video that's going to
tell me all about that person's big idea
what i'm trying to do here is grasp the
concept of the book as quick as possible
it allows me to understand the essential
principles the underlying thought behind
the book from the author without having
to invest a week or a month or however
long it takes to actually finish a book
for you or maybe never so being able to
watch that ted talk watch that youtube
video allows you to figure out whether
you even feel that that topic is
compelling whether you feel attracted to
that subject or whether you feel you
understood it from the talk and might
not even need to read the book basically
my point is that talk should let you
know whether that book is worth reading
for you it should inspire you to want to
go and order it straight away if it
doesn't it's probably a good idea to
skip
no i'm not going to read this
and you don't lose anything you've just
watched a 15 minute talk and learnt
loads of new stuff so i'm going to talk
you through a book that i read last year
it's called the organized mind this
could be any book i'm just using this as
an example because it has some
highlights in it the first thing i do
when i get a book after i've watched the
youtube video or a ted talk i highlight
the sections that i really find
interesting most books today self
development books personal growth books
all split up into parts here you can see
part one part two etc etc and the first
thing i do is i highlight the sections
in that book that stick out to me
straight away it's like going to a menu
and saying i really like the sound of
that i'd love to taste it i really like
the sound of that that's what i want to
learn about and that requires you to be
really conscious of what you're willing
to gain from the book so as you can see
here what i've highlighted in part one
is too much information too many
decisions i want to improve my decision
making so i've highlighted that in part
two i've highlighted organizing our
social world i'm super interested about
how humans connect and so i've also
circled that bit here i'm making a
selection of the parts of the book that
i want to read i always recommend
reading chapter one the author has put
so much energy into that chapter that
you definitely shouldn't miss it but
after that make sure you're highlighting
the spaces that you're really gonna dive
into i recommend highlighting one to two
chapters from each part now you may be
thinking do i start from the
introduction some introductions actually
teach you how to read the book if an
author has done that that's incredible
make sure you read that introduction
apart from that you can start at chapter
one and then make your way through let's
do this so now you've circled the
chapters of interest you can dive
straight into them and as you get into
them i'm going to give you a few quick
tips on how you can make that process
faster and more useful now if you're
someone who loves audiobooks there's
these really cool apps that actually
speed up how quick you can hear now if
you're a reader like me there's a way of
doing that too when you're reading as
simple as it sounds it works you can use
your finger as a guide the more you
speed up your finger times one times two
times three the quicker you'll be able
to read it's the same thing all your
book apps are using right now you listen
at speed one and then move to speed two
and move to speed three you're simply
using your finger as the ability to
start reading faster it actually does
work the other thing you can do is focus
on the most important words in a
sentence we've all seen those examples
where you could actually read words and
paragraphs where all the letters and all
the words are jumbled up because our
brain is able to process the bigger
picture quicker what i recommend is
focus in on the more stronger words in a
sentence hence if a sentence has 12
words you can read the most important
four to six words and still extrapolate
the same meaning even inside a chapter
you can skip to subheadings and
divisions that you find fascinating we
have this fixation on reading every word
finishing every book and finishing every
page the reality is most of us never let
that happen the tips i'm giving you are
going to help you read a book within two
hours or a day and help you decide
whether you want to read the book cover
to cover now imagine if you spent a
month or two months reading a book and
afterwards felt well what did i gain
from that what did i learn from that if
anything what if you read it in two
hours and then had the opportunity to
decide to read the whole thing i
guarantee you when you do it in this way
you'll be able to read books that you
really really value another way to speed
up the reading process is read the first
three lines and last three lines of
paragraphs that you think you might be
interested in if you're not sure when
you do that you'll be able to quickly
contextualize whether that paragraph has
insights that you really want to know
authors place a lot of emphasis in
starting and ending paragraphs with key
information you'll be able to grab it
and decide if you want to read the rest
the interesting thing is when we read
even though it feels like we're flowing
across the words it's not true our eyes
are actually doing a stop start motion
and when i stop we're able to grab
information and when they start we move
to the next so that loses a bit of time
now when you're trying to look at the
most important words you're able to
grasp 90 percent of the meaning which is
looking at 30 of the words it also stops
your eyes from having to constantly do a
stop start motion trying to make it flow
when actually you're jumping to the most
important words in the sentence try it
out with three or five sentences and see
if it works for you now not all these
tools are going to work for you straight
away some of the more simple ones you
can put into practice right away i also
make sure that after a chapter i write
down what i call the 3s formula i write
down a story that really inspired me or
moved me i write down a statistic that i
thought blew my mind and the third thing
i do is i make a note of something i
want to share with someone else that's a
great way of getting more out of a book
now if you're not inspired by a book
drop it finishing a book is nowhere near
as important as actually learning from
it and gaining from it our success
metrics for reading books is how many
we've finished versus how much we've
actually learned so try out whichever of
these tips that work for you make sure
you start off by watching that ted talk
watching that youtube video to grab the
essence of the book the second thing you
want to do is highlight the key chapters
and areas that you really want to dive
into remember it's just like going
shopping you don't need to go through
every aisle to get what you want
remember you can grab as much
information as you need just from the
first three lines and the last three
lines of every paragraph to decipher
whether it's relevant to what you're
reading for and remember when you're
reading if something's not inspiring you
it's not motivating you you're not
learning from it don't drag yourself
through it find the next book and get
working habit number three shift your
identity with ed mylett here's the thing
if you're feeling helpless one of the
antidotes to feeling helpless is to get
more help full
and one of the ways you can be most
helpful is to raise your own identity
our identity is the core part of our
lives we're not going to outperform our
identity our identity best set is it's
the thoughts concepts and beliefs we
hold to be the most true about ourselves
it's really the invisible force in all
of our lives
that holds us back or can accelerate our
success our bliss our achievements to
whole new levels if you look at identity
if you think about it it's almost like
it's the it's a life thermostat see in
this room right now there's a thermostat
sitting on that wall right now and if
it's set at 75 degrees this room is
going to be regulated to 75 degrees no
matter what the external conditions are
it could be 100 degrees outside the
external factors do not impact the
internal thermostat in this room it's 75
degrees consequently also if it was 40
degrees outside the heater will come on
it'll heat this room to 75 degrees
that's how your identity works
it's the internal thermostat of your
life
and that's why very often let's say that
you know relationships or financially
you're a 75 degree
and if you ever notice in your life as
you start to heat life up a little bit
starts to go pretty well maybe your
relationship's blissful and loving and
incredible or financially you've
increased your results you're at 80 85
90 100 degrees of success financially or
in business and then it just seems
coincidental but somehow some way
the air conditioner kicks on in our
lives you know a car breaks down an
event happens we lose an account
something takes place and all of a
sudden we look up and boom life's back
at 75 degrees of relationship of money
of business
that wasn't by coincidence
it is the regulator of your life is your
identity and so if you you can do all
the right things all the activities all
of the thinking all of the execution
part but if you don't increase what you
believe you're worth if you don't
increase that identity that thermostat
of your life you will find a way to cool
your life back down to what you believe
you deserve and so one of the keys for
me in my life is not just getting better
at the mindset of life and the execution
of business or strategy but raising that
identity so that i'm at 85 90 100 120
degrees so that i believe i'm worthy of
as my execution and my thinking reaches
the same level that thermostat setting
that life setting will change
it's not the external conditions of our
life that dictate the terms it's that
identity it's that thermostat setting so
we got to get more helpful if we feel
helpless and the way we do that is by
increasing our own identity that
thermostat setting that sounds great
doesn't it so how do you do that well i
call it the holy trilogy of shifting
one's identity and that is faith
intention
and association that's the three things
you must work on in order to increase
your thermostat setting number one faith
for me it's the center part of my life
is that i have a god who loves me that
believes in me that wants to see me
successful wants to see me prosper wants
to have favor in my life wants me to
feel comfort and peace
and so i find often times there's
interesting people of faith sometimes
god's in their life sunday at church
when they're worshiping or they're in
bible study or when they're eating a
meal they'll pray over it but somehow
when they walk into a business meeting a
speech a board room a client environment
they leave god at the door and they
think they're on their own
so for me if you're a person of faith
and god is with you all the time
and he loves you all the time and he
comforts you all the time that includes
business that includes every area of
your life it includes him wanting to
bless you with a great relationship
bless you financially
bless you to the best of your abilities
in business and then whatever the other
if you're an athlete watching this bless
you in that at bat over that pot
catching that football hitting that shot
and so number one source of shifting
your thermostat setting is reconnecting
again with your faith and allowing
yourself to feel it inside all the other
environments that exist then there's
number two there's your intentions see i
don't think enough people give
themselves credit for having great
intention there's a power to intention
in our lives and so what most of us
think is i'll feel better about myself
or i'll be more confident when when i
get that job when i get that
relationship when i get this amount of
money when i get that house when i hit
that home run when i'm hitting a certain
average
right and so you're always chasing your
tail if your identity and your
confidence is contingent upon producing
a result that has not yet existed
it's pretty difficult to catch it isn't
if you have to have it to get it in the
first place instead of saying
maybe i ought to get credit and i ought
to be worthy of more because i intend to
do well as a young man in business i
started to figure out you know i i may
not have all the answers i may not be
the smartest the best looking the most
articulate my iq isn't 250
but i intend to serve
i intend to make a difference
i make mistakes but overall i'm a good
person who wants to do good in the world
and i should be favored because of that
not enough of you are giving yourself
credit for your intentions you want to
shift your identity overnight connect
with your faith you want to double shift
it connect with your intentions so when
i go into a business meeting or i go
into a lunch or i'm going into any type
of encounter even in my golf life when
my sport i play i remind myself that
i've got a god who loves me who wants me
to win and wants me to be blessed who
wants me to be favored wants me to feel
peace number two
i intend to do good i'm a decent human
being and you know what good things
ought to happen to good people
and then third is association you are
who you hang around see if you're a
85 degree or 75 degree or financially
but you start hanging around someone say
like myself who lives at 100 to 40 150
degrees of finances and wealth and
abundance you will get heated up by
proximity to somewhere in between the
two of us and a lot closer to where i am
than where you are
same thing in relationships if you want
to have a great loving relationship in
your life but you're living at 75
degrees in your relationships you start
hanging around people who are in loving
beautiful relationships your thermostat
setting will increase same within your
faith life if you want to start walking
with more faith in your 75 degrees of
faith if you start hanging around people
who walk their faith life at 150 degrees
you'll be heated up through proximity
and so these are the three things we do
in order to shift our lives our identity
is the governor on our life it is the
most powerful force in the world it's
the invisible force that governs
everything is that thermostat setting
and then if that's true the way we shift
it is always going to be our faith our
intentions and our associations and
those associations are so huge i know
you've all heard you're you know you're
the product of who you hang around the
most often but look at the last 90 days
of your life
okay and ask yourself this question
other than say your spouse or children
who are the two or three four people
you've spent the most time with
picture their faces and their lives
right now and then i want you to measure
one thing what's their emotional
maturity like
see what i find with all successful
people is they have a degree of
emotional maturity that other people are
absent of so i always measure what's
their emotional maturity how do they
handle success how do they handle
failure how do they handle their lives
then ask yourself this
these three or four people you've been
around
can you immediately name two or three
things that they have in their life in
an area that matters to you let's say
it's money let's just say it was money
that they have that you don't have that
you wish you did have
or in relationships do you can you name
two or three things in their
relationships that they have that you
wish you had or in business
or in their physical body
and if you can't immediately go yeah
they got two three four things man i
would love to have that in my life
then i'm not so sure that that's the
person you ought to spend the most time
with the reverse question is also hey
can you name two or three things they
have that you definitely don't want
when you look at their financial life if
finances are important to you do they
have two or three things going on in
their life financially you definitely
want no part of
or in their relationship life you know
if you want a better relationship if you
look at the relationship there are two
or three things like i wouldn't want
that relationship i don't like the way
he or she treats them or they get
treated you look at that or their
physical body you want to be in really
great shape you look at them do they
have two or three things about their
health or wellness that you don't think
are really great well that's an
immediate sign maybe they're the wrong
people and so taking an evaluation of
who your associations are are they
emotionally mature do they have the two
or three things you would like to have
in your life they have in theirs that
you'd like to get heated up and get or
do they have two or three things you
want to avoid these are signs that you
should be away from them so the way we
get more helpful is we increase our
identity and we increase our identity by
working on our faith our intention and
our associations if you do those three
things i believe you're gonna live
happier you'll help other people become
happier you're gonna make a contribution
in people's lives that's deeper and more
meaningful than you've ever made before
and by the way lastly that's what you
were put here to do you were put here
you were born to do something great with
your life in small ways and big ways you
were made to do something awesome with
your life maybe not all that's going to
get limelight or notoriety but you were
born to make a difference in the world
and the more you realize that the more
you step into your intention the more
you step into the person you're capable
of becoming the more you just decide i'm
raising that thermostat setting i'm no
longer this other character i was
playing at any point you and god are the
authors of the lie of your life you can
grab the pen and start to write a new
chapter and say
i'm stepping into this new character
their identities higher they're more
faithful their focus on their intentions
more often they improve their
associations and they help people
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four be solution
oriented with dean graziosi how many
times in life when things go wrong
do we spend too much time
figuring trying to figure out why it
happened
we do relationship goes bad we want to
dig in we have our egos take over we get
passionate we get pissed and how could
that happen to me and why would he do
that the nerve of him or the nerve of
her or why'd my partner take advantage
of me and we spent all this energy going
in what direction backwards
the wrong way
and we don't realize that the quickest
way to the next level is just to
mourn it if you have to be sad about it
but the fact of the matter is you can't
go backwards you can't undo the
situation
you spill a glass of milk you can figure
out who spilt it why it's spilled is it
going to stink is it going to create
mold or you just get a towel and a new
glass of milk
but we don't we take it more serious
than that and the thing is if you're
consciously aware of it you will catch
yourself focusing on why it happened
what went wrong yes you want to you want
to think about it enough to prevent it
from happening in the future but then
the rest is solutions you know i started
this thing i i talk about my kids a lot
if you guys ever watch my weekly wisdoms
the greatest gift in my life is my
kiddos
and i learn so much from their seven and
nine i gotta break it down so simple for
them to get it that it teaches me every
time i try to give them a lesson or
teach them but literally with my kids i
started this about six months ago and
i'm not saying you guys are kids but i
do this now myself even though i made it
up on the on the fly with my kids but
when something comes up and something
goes wrong i literally said hey let's
grab a piece of paper
and i'm like give me four things that
could probably solve this you know i
have baseball i have this at the same
time and i forgot my homework like how
do we solve it how do we solve it i'm
just trying to get them in this rhythm
of understanding that the quickest way
to fix this
is to focus on the solutions and not
only do solutions help because you
actually have a solution it puts your
mind in a different frame
you get to think where you could go what
you could learn from it how you could
solve this and if you can make this
automatic thinking it's really this and
and this
you can
we all suffer on a certain level right
we all suffer things we suffer with work
we suffer if the relationship isn't bad
we suffer if somebody didn't invite us
someplace we suffer if we felt left out
we suffer if our kids are hurting yeah
we're all going to have that but you can
shorten that distance when you're
disappointed or when you fail
the quicker you get to focusing on how
to fix it is the length of your
suffering
how many people do we know that had a
really bad relationship and suffered for
years focusing on what went wrong didn't
get involved in the new relationship had
heartache had pain finally one day they
got over it and said i'm going to do
something about it i'm going to go back
to the gym i'm going to start dating i'm
going to go to match.com it's like you
can decide how long that suffering is
there's no timeline you don't you know
sometimes we we we're suffering and our
stress and our anxiety we wear it as a
badge of honor because sometimes it does
help drive you to another level doesn't
it and then that's kind of a success
trap like i need to worry and stress and
suffer to motivate no you really don't
need to you don't need to i went years
thinking you had two you don't
you don't focus on a solution let
someone else suffer you don't need to
happen number five master your schedule
with russell brunson i used to think
that i was master my schedule i would
start working on a project and next day
i knew it would be 4 am and i'd be like
huh nothing actually got done right or i
forget things right miss appointments
like all sorts of stuff so for me
there's a couple layers of this number
one i bought a huge calendar to my
office that blocks out the big things
like what are the big events happening
when are the trips like what are all the
big things happening so i can see like a
macro level of my year at a glance and
then inside there then i go into my
computer and my phone i've got google
calendars where i block out my daily
schedule right here's my morning routine
here's the things i do every single
morning and every single night every
single lunch that i need to be able to
progress myself forward in whatever
aspect of my life i'm working on and
then on top of that the third tier then
is all the tasks i throughout the day
that are very specific to what i'm
working on right now i got to go film
this video right here i got to go meet
with this person i got to do this
conference i got to have this time
blocked out to be able to think or to
write or whatever things might be and so
blocking out that time and then being
very very protective of it right i do
not share that time with anybody else if
it's blocked on the calendar it has been
claimed it's taken nobody else can have
it i'm gonna be focusing on that in the
moment being as present as humanly
possible and not worrying about all the
other things and all the distractions
that are happening and that way you
could actually get your things done by
the end of the day instead of spending
you know weeks at a time going to three
or four in the morning hoping and
praying you finally get the projects
done how about number six regain your
focus with tom bilyeu what steps can i
take to bring my focus to the one thing
i'm working on while blocking out all
else
all right
so
the real key is you've got to learn to
compartmentalize so what i do to begin
my compartmentalization is i create a
list of all the important things that i
should be working on
i put that list in order this is very
important
getting good at prioritizing is an art
form it is critically important that you
get good at that art form and as you
begin to break things down and put them
in order now you can tell yourself hey
this is what i should be working on
right now so rather than trying to
digest all the different things that
have to be done it's i'm focused on this
one thing right now and my only job
right now is to focus on that thing and
so by not letting your mind wander and
this meditation is very good at bringing
your focus back to the breath which
teaches you to bring your focus back to
whatever so i've got a lot of things
many things competing for my attention
but i know what my important things are
i'm working on the number one thing
right now let's say and so ah this is my
entire world and if i find myself
wandering i bring myself back now part
of the reason that i can invest so
heavily in that is because i have the
belief that that's the most effective
way to work so
since behaviors follow beliefs you want
to make sure that you put that belief in
place which is true by the way that you
can do
everything that you want to do just not
all of it at once so everything has to
be done sequentially you can't do
everything at the same time and this is
why you have to prioritize things out so
if we know
that multitasking is actually a myth and
that you can put people in brain
scanners and what you're seeing people
who seem like they can multitask what
they're doing is called rapid switching
so they don't have what i have which is
high switching costs when i get in a
flow man i can go and go and go but
if i try to bounce back and forth
between things then i pay this high
price and inefficiency between the
switching costs of moving from switching
from that task to this task so i focus i
stay on one thing i have them in order i
know what i'm working on i remind myself
that i only have one job in that moment
that is to work on that thing i know
that that's the most efficient way to
work and i know that i'm good at
prioritizing things so it becomes very
easy boom boom boom and then you just
hold yourself accountable to actually
doing that
practice makes perfect you might have a
difficult time in the beginning start
meditating if you need to to train
yourself to come back to the breath over
and over and over and then you can just
apply that to whatever you're working on
come back to the project and habit
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is have a
journal with nate o'brien one of the
first habits that i adopted was
journaling now i don't like to call it
this because for the most part ninety
percent of what i write down on an
everyday basis is primarily business
oriented but people have different
reasons for
writing things down i think it's very
important for people to essentially dump
their thoughts and have them on paper
somewhere written down now there's a
variety of reasons for this one of them
being that it helps with clarity when
thinking about long-term goals
especially if you're trying to build
wealth or you have
specific goals for yourself in the
coming years by writing them down and
having that there for yourself to look
at there can be times where maybe you
have some struggles maybe you have
some problems or something that you need
to overcome you can go back and look at
what you wrote look at what you were
thinking last week last month five years
ago to better understand your direction
that you should be or you had planned on
going when you were writing things down
now this is also great for other things
not related to business i think
people who are struggling with
depression or struggling with with
issues in their life
writing it down can in a sense be
somewhat therapeutic
and i think it can be all around a
positive for most people to just write
things down dump your thoughts onto
paper and you know i go through one of
these probably almost every quarter i
just write down a lot of my ideas in
them
and it really does help me a lot with
everything in my life and you know i go
back over these after the year and i
look at what i wrote down and sometimes
i laugh sometimes
i think wow you know this is great that
i've been hitting some of these goals
i've been lacking here but i'm going to
write down more in the future
entrepreneurship is one of the hardest
things that you're ever going to do in
your life
and it's totally worth it
it's totally worth it whether it
actually works out or not most
entrepreneurs will fail something like
85 percent of businesses fail in the
first five years most businesses won't
work but it's totally worth it why
because
you're showing yourself that you bet on
yourself you're showing yourself that
you're following through and taking
action on your ideas that you're worthy
you're showing yourself that you're
worthy
you're showing yourself that you believe
in you
and if you keep doing that
you're gonna win
the path to living a happy life a
fulfilled life
a life that you're proud of
is one where you continue to show up for
yourself
and the minute that you stop when you
stop showing up for yourself when you
just throw in the towel and say this is
over i'm just going to work for somebody
else i'm going to help somebody else
build their dreams instead of chasing
down mine
that's when life starts to fall apart
you know that's the path down
to unhappiness and depression and it
doesn't mean that everybody has to be an
entrepreneur
but what you have to do is continue to
bet on yourself you have to continue to
bet on your ideas you have to continue
to say i came up with this good idea
and because i came up with it therefore
it's a worthy endeavor for me to chase
it down
i got asked on my live stream yesterday
how do i know when to quit you know is
quitting is quitting bad
do i quit on something how do i know
when to quit
some people say never give up never give
up always keep going and some people
are the opposites what's the right
advice
the right answer is if you love it you
have to keep going
if you love it you have you have to find
a way to keep going so for a lot of
cases
that's what entrepreneurship is you've
got a dream you've got a mission you've
got some goals that that you genuinely
love that you really want to
to build to create to serve to help
people with
and it's that love that's going to keep
you going
because in the early days it's going to
suck it's the it's the
chewing glass and eating to the abyss
right you have that moment of high at
the beginning of i'm going to start this
thing oh my god it's so exciting and
then you you land into the valley of no
momentum nothing working not no results
nobody praising you anymore nobody's
celebrating you for starting the
business
now you're in the actual running of it
and you're not getting the results that
you want and you're trying to
show how you're winning and post it on
instagram and you're but you're not and
you know you're not and you feel like a
fraud
and this is this is the life cycle that
a lot of entrepreneurs go through
but if you love it
you have to keep going you have to you
have to you have to
you could be a lot more honest you could
be a lot more vulnerable you could be a
lot more authentic
you can understand that you have you
don't have to do this all by yourself
this is my biggest problem when i
started my company i was i was failing i
was flat out failing i was 300 bucks a
month like
failing
and i was too embarrassed and ashamed to
tell my friends that i was feeling i
wanted to look like
i was doing well because i turned down
the jobs that they all went and got and
they're all making
high five figure low six figure jobs at
a university and i'm
making
300 bucks a month i was just embarrassed
i was just too embarrassed and i made it
harder on myself
to be alone
you don't have to be alone you can make
it easier by just letting people in
when you're down in the dumps being by
yourself is usually the worst thing
if you can be around other people
especially people who support you
a lot of people will
let's circle back to
the idea that if you don't love it
you're going to regret it why why do you
have to keep going
why do you have to keep going why is it
so important if you love it because you
will regret it
because you will look back on this
moment in your life and say i should
have
done more i could have done more i
regret not giving it one more week one
more month one more year i regret it you
will regret it that's the only thing
that saved my first business
i quit on my partner i told him i'm done
i need to feel like i'm a valuable human
again nothing i'm doing is working and i
hate how this makes me feel as a person
nothing against
you or the business just how i feel i
need to feel like i'm valuable again
somehow
that was the conversation and then the
next day woke up and i said i can't quit
because i'm going to regret this i know
i'm going to regret this i'm going to be
an old man at 40.
i'm 41 now i'm getting an old man at 40
and regret that i wasted my life and i
didn't do this thing
and that's the only thing that gave me
the the courage
the motivation the energy to get back up
and just keep going you will regret this
if you love it and you stop now you will
regret this for your entire life
now on the flip side i think there are
many things that you should quit on
sooner
the the difference is if you don't love
it you need to quit on it if you don't
love it anymore and maybe you never
loved it in the first place then you
need to move on because you will never
win doing work that you hate
the people who are at the top of their
game people that i've i've studied how
many successful people have i studied
and profiled and showcased on on all of
these channels how many so many people
right the one thing they all have in
common is that they love what they do
they love the process they love the work
they love the grind it's not a grind for
them because they're in it so much and
they love it
so that's who you're going up against
right and if you don't love it you're
always going to lose no matter how smart
you are you're going to lose because
you're going up against people who
absolutely love the thing
and so that's what you need you need to
be loving your thing and so if you're in
it just as a strategy
you're going to lose move on immediately
as soon as your heart's not into it
either sell it or if it's too new then
then you just flat out move on i think
people saying relationships are too long
i think people stay in businesses for
too long because you're afraid of
failure because you're afraid of what it
means if you quit on something and go to
something else you're afraid of what
people are going to say you're afraid of
what the person looking back at you in
the mirror is going to think if you quit
you're afraid of the uncertainty of
where to go next because if this thing
at least i know what this thing is doing
i don't know what the future holds to me
if i go somewhere else
a lot of people are handcuffed by having
a little bit of money not not a lot but
enough to survive
and that then
prevents them from taking the next jump
which they actually need to do because
their hearts aren't in the thing
so many people start a business because
they're just trying to make money
people ask me what's what's the number
one
business to get into for this year to
make a lot of money that's the wrong
question you're asking that question
you're going to lose you can't start
with how to make money you start with
the thing that you love that brings
value and inside of that you're making
money making money is important a
hundred percent if you don't make money
you will not have a business making
money has to be in your top five of
priorities but if you make it number one
you're gonna lose because you're always
gonna be chased in the next hot thing
never get good enough at anything to
actually be the best in the world which
is actually how you start to make a lot
of money you need to be the best in the
world at something how do you get that
by loving the things so much
and by wanting to serve and help people
get better at it too
that's how you win in that year when i
was really broke and i was really broken
i was working at la unified school
district
i was miserable
i was miserable because i wasn't living
in my dream i was just doing a j.o.b
and then one day
i said well what what do i need to do i
i need to i need to buy my freedom
that's what i need to do i need to buy
my freedom well i don't know about
buying my freedom i don't know about
buying i don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up
my mother used to tell me oh this money
is burning my pocket so i know two
things about money it's hot
and we can't keep it long
we'd always have one week when we had
all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty right come on
come on some of you guys know about that
to this day i spend so much money on
groceries you guys oh my god it's like
i'm feeding like a family of ten
because i'm so afraid of anybody ever
being at my house and being hungry
and so i i wrote a check to myself
jelani was three
a hundred and ten dollars
i took it to the bank
wells fargo
i started a new account
the next check i wrote
125
and just like the first check i put in
the memo line funding my dream i wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but i knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
i'm not even clear about it i don't know
how clear you are but i wasn't clear
about it but i knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for la
unified school district and no
disrespect to l.a unified school
drinking it just wasn't my destiny
i wrote another check in two weeks
146
funding
my dream
now i started mailing the checks in
because i didn't want to see my balance
because i didn't want to go shopping
because i you're going to repeat what
you learn right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned
so i mailed the check in and then i
wrote another check
and i wrote another check and every
check i wrote i made sure it was five
percent more than the first check the
previous check
i sold my ultima i had a car note sold
my ultima bought a clunker because it
didn't have a car note now i can write a
bigger check funding my dream
i moved out of my three bedroom three
bed three bath house and moved in became
a roommate with my friend who smoked i
put towels at the base of the door so
the smoke wouldn't come through the door
i was willing to be inconvenienced are
you
yes yes i'm just saying i'm just i'm
just showing you the story i just the
charge i just gave you i stopped getting
my hair done that was when i started
going natural
i stopped going out
i stopped going out dancing i stopped
going out to dinners my family didn't
know what was going on they thought oh
my god you know it's la she's on drugs
but she's not losing weight so maybe not
i don't know what's going on
i kept writing bigger checks to myself
900
900
i mailed it to wells fargo
funding my dream
eleven hundred dollars
mailed it to wells fargo
funding my dream
i still
wasn't clear
what the dream was
i just knew i had one
and it was being born through me
and i needed to give it a chance
that's all i knew
you don't have to see 2 000 feet in
front of you just see 200
and run to the 200.
yes yeah yes yes you don't have to see
it all
three and a half years later i've
written a check to myself every two
weeks for three and a half years
i didn't go out for three and a half
years i didn't go dancing i didn't get
my hair done i did get my nails done for
three and a half years are you willing
to be inconvenienced for your conviction
i walk in to wells fargo three and a
half years later
and i said hi god bless you hi
my name is lisa nichols she goes oh my
god
you're the fun of my dream lady
i was like
yeah i guess i am
and all of a sudden all the tellers came
running around
the manager came they're like oh my god
okay oh my god we have been wondering we
all got the same question y'all know
what the question is right what's your
dream
i was like um
i'm not sure
but i know that it includes inspiring
people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
get having to be willing to give
themselves a thousand second chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
i'm not sure what it's going to look
like
but it's just going to help people
i said i came to check my balance i've
been
writing a few checks to you guys that
say yes you've been writing a lot
i said i just want to check my balances
you don't know your balance to know i
got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home because my mama
said money burns her pocket and i don't
want it to burn my pocket i wanted to
pay for my freedom
i said i just came to see what my
balance was if i had enough to fund my
dream as it gets clearer
she wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me
i looked at it i said
oh no my name is lisa shantay nichols
and my social security number i said
that is not my money and i am not taking
that money because you're probably gonna
want it back
so just fix that error right now
and they looked at me
they said you really don't think that's
yours
i said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank
or ten thousand dollars in the bank
that's
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
in the bank
they said miss nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said miss nichols
whatever your dream is
i think you can fund it now
i looked at my son jilani
who now was five or six and i said
jelani
our lives are gonna be a little
different now baby
jilani said
yeah
mommy can we
can't we now go to mcdonald's
see for three years i've been telling
jelani i'll make you a big mac
mama makes big macs better than
mcdonald's
and so it began
with a hundred and ten dollar check
so i don't know what yours is i don't
know
what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right
yes yes
and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the best the next
best step this is the first step
and so i just stopped by to let you know
you're on the right path
and and as you ramp up
as you ramp up you're going to have
questions you're going to be afraid i do
more things afraid now than i do
fearless
because the bigger you play
the bigger your breakdowns
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one
every single one of my errors has
required me to call an attorney
[Laughter]
like they're just big
because i'm playing big
i'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here
be willing
to go to the edge
and not just lean over
and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump
and watch them soar and look through the
windows and all the people who are
living great lives don't just go to the
edge and feel it
be willing to lean
feel your heartbeat
feel it
that lets you know you're alive
to let you know you're okay
fear fuels you
fear lets you know go get more
information fear let you know step a
little later and study fear let you know
get up a little earlier fear let you
know ask for help fear is informing you
it's not stopping you it's just another
emotion like love and compassion and
gratitude we just made it paralyze us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear i feel it and i'm moving
forward anyway i feel it and i'm gonna
love anyway i feel it and i'm gonna
invest in me anyway i feel it and i'm
gonna show up and play anyway when you
get connected with fear it becomes your
best friend and when you stand on the
edge
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap
anyway speaking of learning from lessons
you've been around a lot of incredible
entrepreneurs and i know you did a
reality show with richard branson says
10 12 years ago you said yes what was
that like and what's been a big lesson
you've learned from him and what was the
show and
what'd you learn yeah the show was
called the rebel billionaire and it was
the apprentice version richard branson's
version of that they were looking for 16
entrepreneurs so i'm like hey i'm an
entrepreneur i want to do this and i
really wanted to meet richard i sort of
had set intentions out there that i was
going to manifest him becoming a friend
in my life so when i heard about the
show i was like oh this is interesting
this might be how this happens so i
applied for it and um
uh it was wild so it's how big how big
was spanx at the time was it really well
known was it like just kind of it was
pretty i mean it was four years in it
was doing great yeah multiple seven
figures
yeah my lawyers begged me not to do it
they're like what are you doing you own
this company you're going to do a
reality show i was like i just want to
know richard i just feel like this is a
chance so um
so
yeah and all the business challenges
took place around the world in different
cities and instead of if you didn't win
the business challenge going into a
board room to get fired you had to do a
crazy stunt like a world record breaking
stunt because richard is obviously
like a huge adrenaline junkie guy so um
in addition to being an amazing
entrepreneur and the very first day of
filming i had to climb the side of a hot
air balloon at 9 000 feet in the air on
a dangling rope ladder and have tea
climb to the top and have tea on top of
the balloon with richard insane it's
insane
what did you guys talk about on the top
oh my god i talked about like how do we
get down and that's what he said you
climb back down i was like what i didn't
think about that it was so scary yeah oh
my gosh yeah so it took me 48 minutes to
climb to the top it's at the height of a
17-story building and the dangling rope
ladder was just like hanging out into
the abyss of nothingness wasn't anchored
to anything so i'm like climbing it
and um there's cameras that was the
first day of filming so two months later
i know i like cameras up there
yes
helicopters circling
probably probably
i had to do all these crazy stunts the
next stop i had to do is i had to jump
off the side of the victoria falls gorge
in africa
on a with a bungee cord attached to me
and my guy on my team was dangling on a
wire on a crane
10 feet out from the cliff and each
person had to come up and stand there
and you couldn't run and jump and you
had to stand still and jump and if he
caught you you were okay and they'd put
you back on the cliff and if not you
fell 385 feet
on a bungee cord
and so i am beyond terrified of heights
it's like one of my i'm so afraid of
heights i cry on airplanes still during
takeoff a lot of times
and
i was one of the only people to make the
jump richard didn't make the jump all
these other guys that were like amazing
athletes didn't make the jump and i like
to talk about this because i always talk
about aiming high and the importance of
aiming high in life and then i i think
all of us we don't aim high enough
and so watch where you're aiming and
that that's saying you know if you shoot
for the moon if you miss here at least
with the stars and afterwards everyone
was like sarah how did you make that
jump you're literally like the only
contestant and look at you i said well i
was aimed at the pulley six feet above
his head where were you aiming and i
aimed i didn't even look at him i aimed
six feet above his head and i landed at
his waist and he caught me and everybody
else was aiming at his face and landed
at his feet and missed
amazing so it's like a really just
poignant
example of the importance of aiming high
my dad did a style of martial arts
called kyokushinkai
and um
and i suppose this little boy trying to
get close to dad i was like well if he's
doing it i'm going to join him
so my dad and i shared this incredible
passion of martial arts and cars right
um
so i kind of get started you know with
my father then he gets gunned down when
i'm 13 years old
and i went through like a year of just
nothing i just i couldn't show up at the
dojo i didn't have it in me
and i did all the things we're talking
about the excuses at the time south
africa had a a particularly high crime
problem
and i was like you know what's the point
you know he has a first degree black
belt who gets attacked he get takes nine
bullets and he's dead anyway why am i
going to this thing called the dojo
right
again excuses valid it really is
but there's no progress
so a year nothing
and then and then i was like i actually
miss it so i went back
it was interesting when i went back it
wasn't the same
i wasn't doing the qatar
to impress the senseis anymore
i was doing the cutter because i wanted
every single movement
to be as close to flawless as i could
get it
it changed my entire perspective so
one of the things that happened you're
gonna love this i'm literally getting
chills thinking about it one of the
things that happened is time
just expanded
so right because we have a very finite
construct of time i'm gonna be at the
dojo for an hour
but what happened was that hour be felt
like five hours and sometimes 30 minutes
felt like five
all of a sudden this fixed construct of
time
you know it started to change because my
relationship with what i was doing
changed
so it wasn't just a punch it wasn't just
the cutter i wasn't just i wasn't just
showing up for the emotion
i was embedded in every single part of
the process i was looking for growth for
progress right
i have to tell you that changed my
entire life
so anytime i find myself stuck now
i i recognize that often the reason i'm
stuck is because i'm focusing on the
output and i'm not focusing on my input
right so output i've got to raise a
hundred million around for my business
output i've got to get 300 growth for
you know in customers output i've got to
get 25 yeah that's all output
but what you got to focus on is input
what are the things i've got to do and
how do i do those things intentionally
deliberately and try to get better every
single time every meeting every impact
conversation with one of my staff
members every engagement with a client
or a potential client every single one
of those things how do i focus on that
moment because actually the output is a
sum total of how those things come about
so when you
when you are at the dojo and you are
being graded and you are going through
the process of trying to attain your
black belt or your brown belt that's
what everybody sees is the output but
what actually went in was that malleable
construct of time
where you're trying to perfect every
single
movement you will find true success and
happiness
if you have only one goal there really
is only one and that is this
to fulfill
the highest
most truthful
expression of yourself
as a human being
you want to max out your humanity
by using your energy to lift yourself up
your family and the people around you
theologian howard thurman said it best
he said don't ask yourself what the
world needs
ask yourself what makes you come alive
and then go do that
because what the world needs is people
who have come alive
the world needs
[Applause]
[Music]
people like michael stalzenberg from
fort lauderdale when michael was just
eight years old michael nearly died from
a bacterial infection that cost him both
of his hands and both of his feet
and in an instant this vibrant little
boy became a quadruple
amputee and his life
was changed forever
but in losing who he once was
michael discovered who he wanted to be
he refused to sit in that wheelchair all
day and feel sorry for himself so with
prosthetics he learned to walk
and run and play again
he joined his middle school lacrosse
team
and last month when he learned that so
many victims of the boston marathon
bombing would become new amputees
michael decided to banish that darkness
with light
michael and his brother harris created
mikeysrun.com
to raise one million dollars for other
amputees by the time harris runs the
2014 boston marathon
more than a thousand miles away from
here
these two young brothers
are bringing people together to support
this boston community the way their
community came together to support
michael and when this 13 year old man
was asked about his fellow amputees he
said this
first
they will be sad
they're losing something
they will never get back
and that's scary
i was scared
but they'll be okay
they just don't know that yet
we might not always know it
we might not always see it or hear it on
the news
or even feel it in our daily lives but i
have faith
that no matter what
class of 2013
you will be okay
and you will make sure our country is
okay
i have faith because of that
nine-year-old girl who went out and
collected the change
i have faith because of david and
francine wheeler i have faith because of
michael and harris stolzenberg and i
have faith because of you the network of
angels sitting here today one of them
khadijah williams
who came to harvard four years ago
khadijah had attended 12 schools in 12
years
living out of garbage bags
amongst pimps and prostitutes and drug
dealers
homeless
going into department stores walmart in
the morning to bathe herself so that she
wouldn't smell in front of her
classmates
and today she graduates as a member of
the harvard class of 2013. revisit your
orientation to wealth if i say to you
rich people
what does that bring up for you
when you think about rich people what do
you think of
are they good
are they bad are the rich one two three
four percent of the world good people
bad people what do they like what are
their values like
do you want to become one of them
you know i don't know about you but
sometimes you discover that where you
live or where you came from or what you
heard of about money in your life is
absolutely unconsciously driving your
life today like for example for me i
grew up in a very difficult economic
situation i grew up in a very difficult
town and place and an old irish mining
town that had been economically
depressed for nearly a century where
people didn't have a lot and people
really struggled just you know very
blue-collar tried to get through the day
lots of poverty lots of people
struggling and i can share with you that
there was this conversation often about
people on the other side right there's
people on the other side of the tracks
or there's people on the other side who
are wealthier and there was a lot of the
culture that i grew up in where oh those
rich people
and there was this projection of
frustration or restlessness or anger
towards quote unquote rich or wealthier
people and because of that i didn't ever
want to become one of them
and so i didn't for a very long time
it's funny because one of the basic
human drives that we have is the human
drive for congruence we want to be
congruent in our thoughts and our
behaviors so if we think that a type of
person is negative our body and our mind
and our subconscious will do everything
it can not to become that right we don't
want to become something that we think
is negative so if you think wealthy
people or rich people are negative guess
what you're never going to attain
wealth
and that's what's important to revisit
all those old stories and all those old
phrases we heard growing up you know you
know
money's the root of all evil or people
are you know people with money are
insensitive or people with money are
selfish or if you gain more wealth and
success in life you're just going to be
more busy and you're never going to have
time for your family and you're going to
forget everybody whoever came along with
you and never supported you and oh my
god and all these things right we think
this big story about money
so what's your story about money
is it positive is it negative is wealth
something that will bring you more joy
more happiness more ability to give and
serve and do something with in your life
or is it something that terrifies you
because you think you won't be able to
handle the obligations that come along
with us
you worry that if you make more money or
to make more money you're gonna have to
be away from your family more so you
never try
see most of us have a lot of really bad
assumptions about what it would take to
succeed but also what it would take to
make more money and ultimately to keep
more money to sustain more money because
i bet you also think oh i heard it's
lonely at the top
well who wants to be lonely and if rich
people are bad who wants to be a bad
person and rich people are
you know pushing family members away and
becoming selfish who wants to become
that
so you've got to redefine what wealth
would mean for you specifically not what
the culture told you it could be i will
share with you that after you know i've
been through the ringer financially in
my life i mean i grew up with nothing
and then i started making something in
corporate america and built something of
myself i started working really hard i
got a good job i started climbing sort
of that corporate ladder i discovered
that the corporate world wasn't for me
and so i left i quit and to start my own
dream of doing videos and and writing
and doing my seminars and and and all of
the things that i do now and you know
what i did exactly what people predicted
i promptly went bankrupt i went broke i
had no idea what i was doing and it
would have been easy at that point very
easy to quit very easy to say oh you
know what money's not for me but i
thought no i know that sometimes you
know if you don't have money you can't
sustain the message if you're not
earning then you can't keep giving and i
thought i got to change my orientation
here i got to get serious
about making money and do it without all
the guilt and the nonsense that my
culture or the past or the popular media
thrusts on people with money because
guess what there are also
philanthropists there are also people
who take money and they support their
family they send their kids to college
they get safer cars they do good in
their community they buy books for kids
they do things that matter with their
wealth and matter of fact that's most
wealthy people
and people it's really hard for to
believe that if you're not wealthy yet
but i can share with you after i had my
big breakthrough and i started learning
how to build more value in the
marketplace everything shifted for me
for the first time in my life i had
money and the funniest thing is i didn't
even know what to do with it because i
never had it before so it was just there
and guess what i've started finding
things to do with it no problem as you
will
but those things i found to do with
money they didn't tear me from my family
or make me a bad person
i gave more to charities
i spent more time with my family i could
take them on vacations we could go to
the caribbean together i i could do
things for people that i love little
gifts and little treats and little
acknowledgements that made them feel
happy i found ways to utilize it that
made me happy and now i had no negative
associations to it anymore
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want seven more
rich people habits for you to try check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there you guys are just
getting started
you're not gonna start right here
you're gonna start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother